hey guys it is the 19th of June my name
is Jess McDowell and we're gonna make GS
news happen hopefully does better than
fetch Ubisoft have saddled up to which a
dev CD Projekt RED in thing that DRM is
not gonna stop piracy you be said quite
rightly that they reckon any game can be
cracked with enough time and effort and
that they'd rather put that time into
making games people actually want to pay
for VP of digital publishing for the
company Chris early said I don't want us
in a position where we're punishing a
paying player for what a pirate can get
around anything is going to be able to
be parted given enough time and effort
to get in there so the question becomes
what do we create as services or is
benefits and the quality of the game
that will have people just want to pay
for it he also noted that baking in
online experiences that aren't available
to gamers with illegal copies is a good
way to fight the Pirates the criminal
ones not the assassin's creed one man I
guess they really want us to keep using
you play meanwhile CEO of Ubisoft is
glamour has not given up on the wii u
and so neither should you well i mean
you can do whatever you want but here's
what Yves had the same Guillermo
explained to CVG with mario kart where
you made one step and we can expect with
smash brothers it will also do more if
Nintendo put the right price on the
machine then they will probably have a
chance to do further the console
currently retails for 299 BOTS and has
sold 6.7 1 million units as a much 31
this year guillermo rounded off by
hinting at a shelved Wii U game the QB
has lying around and by stating that a
larger software collection and install
based is likely to set the console up
for a brighter 2014 and yet more Ubisoft
news watch dogs are getting an official
patch complete with improvements to
performance and stability you can find
the complete list of fixes on games but
but in summary the pc and console patch
will do things like result game breaking
bugs address graphical glitches
increased performance and generally make
the game a whole lot better the pc
version of the patch will be coming in
the next
few days and as what is certainly my
favorite headline of the week so far
Ubisoft we're actually now i'm just
gonna give it to you verbatim ubisoft
pleasantly surprised by fan reaction to
elephants Ubisoft Montreal have
commented on the fact that we were all
like holy crap elephants after this
year's far cry 4 reveal much like we
were all holy crap man-eating Tigers
when we got our first glimpse of far cry
3 if you want in the know you can ride
and control far cry 4 elephants so if
you want to trampy daddies and get
around in style you'd be mad to go for
any other options level design director
Mark Thompson says the fact that it's
part vehicle part weapon and it's just
generating so many more players stories
than we thought it's great to see just
how excited people get when they get
hands on with that elephant let me know
in the comments if you're keen for the
pachyderms or if there's another animal
in video games that holds a special
place in your heart that is it from me
today I'll be back tomorrow with my top
five favorite stories of the entire week
if you need to get caught up so I'll see
you then